so mr. Comey where are we now what has
changed since your memoir came out apart
from the fact that you sewed a lot of
copies has been a lot of discussion
around it but what's materially changed
I don't think much that we've continued
to see and struggle in the States
especially with the implications of this
president's way of approaching his job
most prominently in the issue of
children being separated from their
families on the southwest border that
that's a really important thing because
it illuminates America's values in a way
and the way the president threatens them
that's a really important change since
the book came out but President Trump
has just signed an executive order
reducing family separation at the border
so he does look like he's trying to
address that do you think that's a sign
that there is you know Donald Trump is
often seems not responding much to
criticism you know him well you've
described him up close that possibly he
does he takes on more than he wants to
show that he takes on that maybe so I
don't know for sure I think what you see
here is the American Giant is the way I
like to think about it the American
people are the embodiment of our values
and they're normally very busy and
living their lives and so they're not
involved in politics but they saw what
was happening at the border and without
regard to political orientation they
rose up and expressed their disgust and
that forced action by the president and
the issue itself is important but
actually the awakening may be more
important and of more long-lasting
importance to the country Melania Trump
has just been on a visit to the border
and has been photographed getting on Air
Force One wearing the jacket with the
logo I really don't care and blazoned on
it what do you make of that
I saw the pictures I don't know what to
make of it I saw her spokesperson I
think said it's just a jacket it's not a
message so I'm not cool enough to know
whether that's a statement about fashion
or something beyond that but you've seen
how team Trump operates close up do you
think the mother Melania Trump that
you've encountered
it would do that without messaging
something I don't know I don't know her
I've never met her team Trump itself at
least to my eyes doesn't have a
consistent strategy and isn't
particularly competent at executing
whatever their strategy is so I I don't
assume malevolence when when accident or
incompetence is an available explanation
do you think you might simply be
incompetence or an accident or I I
really can't speculate I don't I don't
want to over-interpret a jacket and I
take her spokesperson at his word that
it's a jacket I wouldn't think that
someone going to visit a Center for
incarcerated migrants would wear a
jacket that to send a message like I
don't care you're going because you care
so I I don't know the answer I guess I
shouldn't speculate and I'm not I'm not
cool enough about fashion to have any
more insight you previously said that he
was morally unfit to be president has
your overall opinion of the presidency
shifted at all
mine has not my concern about the
president is actually not at the policy
level it's at the moral level about the
way in which our values are threatened
especially the rule of law and the truth
by his behavior and I think what we've
seen over the last couple months just
increases my concern and that's what I
meant by the awakening of the giant I
think more and more Americans are coming
to realize we have to worry about that
that higher level of the values of
America because we lose that we've lost
everything the force of your argument
has always been it's better to oppose
Donald Trump through the usual electoral
process rather than impeachment or any
other mechanism by which one could hope
to get rid of a president that some
people don't like but are you still
confident when you look at the lay of
the land of American politics the Donald
Trump wouldn't be reelected yeah I don't
know I'm not at all confident that he
won't be reelected I'm I'm hopeful that
the American people will wake up to the
threat to our values that he won't be
but there's scenarios in which I could
imagine especially if there are three
candidates for president this may be his
dad
to get reelected with 33 34 percent of
the vote which represents his base I
don't know I think it's really important
that we talk about it and I'm optimistic
I shouldn't be that optimistic yet I'm
hopeful that the Democrats will pick a
candidate who reflects our values in a
way that attracts the great middle of
American life you know I think you might
be making the political judgment error
of assuming that many more people are
actually angry and it's crossed with mr.
Trump as you are know I'm I hope you
don't hear me to be assuming that I
that's why I'm being careful and
actually saying he could get reelected
I'm I know that the rhythm of American
history is we find ourselves in these
kinds of places over and over again and
the American values recover and win in
the end but whether it takes four years
or six years for the American people to
realize what's at stake here I can't say
don't Trump's to to come on a visit to
London in in the near future if indeed
he does there's been some controversy
and I think it has taken light again
after this situation at the border
saying the Democratic politicians of the
West should be much tougher on him
possibly not receive him at all sitting
here in London what would do you think
should he be the next big American
visitor to town or not well he's the
President of the United States and so
I've obviously been highly critical of
him on an ethical basis but I respect
the office and I and I think that that's
the way it should be across countries if
the American people aren't happy with a
British Prime Minister I would expect
them to treat that person with respect
and not to cut off contact simply
because of disagreements so the
relationship is more important than any
person or any one term so I would hope
that it would be treated like a
presidential visit but in a way you
didn't treat the president like any
other president you wouldn't have
written a memoir about any other
presidents that you note in the terms
that you did Donald Trump right and I I
think the distinction is logical that I
respect the office of President and I
actually want president Trump to be
successful if he's able to achieve the
complete verifiable
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
I will be in I certainly a lot of other
people feel this way to praise that that
achievement but at the same time I have
to speak as an American about the threat
to our values that I think he poses I
think that's my obligation as an
American
what's cool about being in a democracy
like the UK or America is I also have
the opportunity to do that and are you
optimistic about the North Korea do you
nuclearization do I'm not I again I look
at the rhythm of history and see that
we've actually been in this place before
with the North Koreans and they don't
follow through on the lovely sounding
promises so I think everybody ought to
approach it with a deep sense of
skepticism let's turn to the Department
of Justice report on the FBI
handling of the Hillary Clinton emails
inquiry in your role in that the report
said you were insubordinate basically
that you were overstepped in that case
the new FBI director Christopher Rea
says he can't imagine taking a similar
decision it must give you pause for
thought about your own the processes
that led you to that decision of course
it does I had pause about my process at
the time and I agree with director ray I
could never have imagined myself in a
situation where we were investigating
one of the two candidates for president
of the United States during the election
year and the circumstances that I was
presented with surfaced and I if you'd
asked me in 2015 could I imagine
stepping away from the Attorney General
to announce separately the FBI's
recommendation in a case no way that's
the nature of five hundred year floods
they come every 500 years but did it
need to come precisely on the eve of the
election was that the question wasn't it
him whether why did you announce it
we have me on the eve of the election
hadn't you had new evidence for some
time I mean innocence maybe you were a
victim of your own delaying tactic I
don't think so I don't know what you
mean by delaying tactic I it was very
hard on the heels or what the word is it
was before just very shortly before the
election and that was the problem Oh
my goodness yes that's what made it a
nightmare and so you had two choices at
that point you could speak about it or
not speak about it either one of those
choices is bad one in my view is
catastrophic not speaking once you've
told the American people something
they're relying on not to correct it is
to perpetrate a lie but other people can
see it differently the Inspector General
saw it differently and I respect that I
think it's a serious error of judgment
yep
and I did you look into yourself and
question I mean generally once we've
made a decision we find reasons why it
was the right decision you know you
wouldn't be alone in that did you look
at your own judgment Oh
at the time repeatedly for a day and a
half in agony and since then many many
times and I don't see it differently I
really don't and I've tried to
cross-examine myself because I know that
people tell themselves awesome stories
about themselves what's the hardest
question you ask yourself was there
another alternative was there a way out
was there something I didn't see at the
time hindsight is useless to me again I
know now that the the agency was able to
complete the review before the election
but I couldn't have known that on
October 28th so are there things I could
have known then and should have known
one big one is should I have known about
the Hillary Clinton this huge trove of
new emails and acted on it a month
earlier that's a really hard question
one the IG the inspector general
wrestles with in their report suggesting
that you missed it I don't think they're
suggesting that I think they're
suggesting that the FBI as an
organization should have moved on it
faster and presented it to me earlier
and and I can't really answer that
because I didn't I didn't index on it no
one brought it to me in a form that I
could act on it but that's a big what-if
for me Hillary Clinton has a jibe about
your own use of private gmail account
obviously circumstances differ she was
Secretary of State etcetera but
optically I mean can you say that that
is you know that she might
well have an eye-roll about the fact
that you used your own private Gmail
casually when that was at the heart of
the problems that you threw up for her
yes but it's a bit depressing that if
she sees it that way because that means
she missed what the point of the entire
investigation was wasn't about her use
of a private email or AOL or a private
account it was about the treatment of
classified information we'd have had the
same issue if she were using an
unclassified government system no one's
claiming that I used a Gmail for any
classified communications I used it to
send draft speeches back and forth to
myself and so it's a little bit
depressing that after she's missing the
point
deliberately or missing the point
because you doesn't want to take it on
board I don't know I don't know her well
enough to know during the campaign she
used to frequently say well Secretary of
State Colin Powell used a o L which
missed the point then no one was
claiming that Powell just as with me was
talking about classified things on an
unclassified email system so it's
possible she's had a misconception of it
throughout she's quite right woman is
she really having a misconception of
what the investigation wasn't it I don't
know which is why I can't express it
with certainty I can just say it's
possible because otherwise it's hard to
explain their focus on : Powell
her I roll tweet I just I don't know
what I I really don't think she'd be
well I guess I can't say you don't think
it's fair that she should have a jibe at
you feel use of private gee no I get why
she would do it it would be fun in a way
to jab me even if you knew what the case
was about
but again throughout it she would say my
predecessors used unclassified private
email systems which missed the point as
well you talk in the book about your
regrets and sometimes even a sense of
panic really that you may have impacted
the election and swung the election for
Donald Trump because by this stage you
know how they're saying you don't think
he's fit to be President to it
do you do you I assure you that you
made any difference really and have you
changed your mind at all about that as
the presidency has gone on I hope I made
no difference at all my wife who was a
strong supporter of Hillary Clinton's
hopes there'll be a scientific study at
some point that proves I had no impact
whatsoever and this may sound strange
but it doesn't change how I think about
the decision that I had to make on
October 28th because I don't think the
FBI director can make decisions based on
partisan considerations so even if
someone had showed me that if we made
this decision it would have the
following impact I don't think you can
legitimately consider that in the role
that I was in
and again I've read a fair number of
things by experts trying to figure out
whether we had an impact and the answer
is likely we'll never know and it's also
part of a normal human phenomenon to
blame the last cause that is when a team
that's heavily favored in a match loses
the match you tend to focus on the
goalie missing a stop in the last 30
seconds and not focus on the fact that
you gave up four goals in the first
period and why did that happen I get why
people focus on that point at the end
but I don't know whether it made a
difference do you think you scored an
own goal well I don't know again again
whether I had an impact on the election
and I hope it doesn't sound facetious it
in a way it doesn't matter to the
decision it makes it more painful it
makes me sick to my stomach to think
that we had any impact but I don't I
can't sit here and tell you we had an
impact that's for others to figure out
what I think is so fascinating you know
listening to you talk now and thinking
what you wrote in the book as you spent
a career clearly cultivating a
nonpartisan image and you ended up in a
position where lines like this could be
written about you mr. Comey believed he
alone could protect public trust but he
negatively impacted the perception of
the FBI and someone said to me yesterday
you were the most politically active
director of the FBI since Jagga Hoover
fair know whatever what you mean by
politically active I and the FBI really
overly involved in politics well when
you're the
referee in a World Cup match are you
involved in football in a sense you're
on the field and you have to make calls
but that doesn't mean you're on one team
or the other or rooting for one team or
the other the FBI found itself
investigating one of the two candidates
for President of the United States
during the election we were doomed in a
way the decisions I made were all made
trying to pick the least bad of terrible
options to protect the institution in
the long run and honestly even in
hindsight and I've asked myself this a
thousand times I think we made the best
decisions of course it led to damage to
the FBI but the question you have to ask
is compared to what if I had chosen not
to speak on the cusp of election and
concealed that we restarted that
investigation I think I'd be reading an
Inspector General report today
excoriating me for damaging the FBI for
the rest of my life but also writing the
memoir is a political act and it comes
at a time we haven't yet had the murder
investigation conclude so this could be
seen to you feed into a mood of
hostility coming out of the FBI and some
other details in the report would
appeared about up in these in some cases
a political hostility to the president
that of course then puts the FBI in the
spotlight on that charge have you aided
that with this memoir I don't think so I
want to reject your premise a little bit
respectfully that I don't see writing
this book which isn't a memoir because
there's lots of stuff I think is
important to my life that's not in there
it's a book about what we can be or
should be as leaders I don't see that as
a political act unless you define
political to include participating in
debates in your country about things
like ethics and leadership and how we
ought to be I would be true if you were
another private citizen however senior
but you're a former director of the FBI
and on the whole that has not been the
approach that they wrote memoirs
afterwards attacking the president well
that's actually not true Louis Freeh one
of the directors two directors before me
wrote a memoir afterwards excoriating
Bill Clinton
but I actually think about it the
reverse that it would be an abdication
of my responsibility as an American not
to participate right now I have a
perspective that almost nobody does
because of where I worked and what I did
and my life would actually be bet as
much as I'm enjoying talking to you my
life would be better if I weren't
sitting here talking I'm horrified to
hear this but I think that would be a
cowardly thing to do and I'm not doing
this to me didn't pause because you'd
already had problems with timing I mean
inevitably and whoever was in your shoes
would have had this knowing what we now
know but Clinton investigation and about
the Russia investigation timing was
never going to be your friend or could
have waited till after the murder
inquiry you could have you could have
waited till things had sort of basically
the whole story had been flushed out on
possible collusion with Russia so the
charge is you're getting in the way with
this memoir yeah I get that but I really
don't think so and here's why and I say
this as an experienced prosecutor
investigator my account to the extent
I'm a witness is locked down
I wrote the memos right after the events
I testified under oath about it a year
ago so there's very little chance that
that I will affect my own ability to be
a witness but what would be the right
time I'd really I'm not really going to
interview you but I turned the question
out so what would be the right time I
published a book a year after I left
office and could I really look myself in
the mirror if my concerns are about
ethics and morals by this president
could look at myself in the mirror if I
waited until the damage was more severe
to speak about it I couldn't and so
there's never a good time again it's not
fun actually to write a book and go out
and talk about the American president
like this but I think this is a
reasonable time to do it and if I did
otherwise I would be a bit of a coward
what confidence do you have that the
Robert Miller investigation will bring
out the truth and then have a meaningful
impact about what it is able to show
those are two different questions I have
high confidence that if the special
prosecutor is allowed to complete his
work given the nature of him his quality
his character and his people he
we'll develop the facts that allow us
all to see what is true that that I have
high confidence in what will happen as a
result of what he finds I can't say and
don't know so I can't express a view on
that
you don't express if you you're just not
sure how it will play out I don't have a
view that would be thoughtful because I
can't see what he's gonna end up finding
and then there's a next question about
our political system what will the
reaction be and by whom too hard to say
at this point you testify to someone who
is your predecessor in in office and to
some people this sort of sense that
everybody knows everybody else either
from the FBI or from other associations
in law enforcement looks a bit cozy why
are they wrong to be a bit suspicious or
skeptical well they're wrong because
they need to make sure they stare at the
people of what they're like what their
track record is like there's no doubt
that in all countries there's a fairly
small group of people who are expert in
particular areas law enforcement is one
of them and so that would prompt you to
ask so what are these people like what
is what is Robert Muller like and like
he is the straightest person I have ever
known he is a person who does not care
about expediency or politics or any of
the things that govern a lot of what
goes on in Washington and he's exactly
the person you would want doing this
kind of work and you wouldn't see some
truth in the fact that that you have
given fresh ammunition to Donald Trump
and his supporters and some of his his
you know attack dogs in the media and
elsewhere for his kind of aggressive
stance or attack on institutions you
didn't feel you fed into that I don't
think so I mean he started he fired me
on television and then started attacking
me and my credibility and my character
immediately and so I've published this
book a year later and that year I didn't
do a single press interview during that
year and
and so I didn't need I didn't need to
feed the attack mechanism it was well
well underway long before I published
the book and one of the things that in
the investigation is looking at its
possible obstruction of justice in your
firing and in the handling of your case
by the Trump administration do you feel
that justice was obstructed in your own
particular example I don't know it could
be but I as a witness I can't see enough
to give you a final judgement on that
that's something that the special
prosecutor will have to figure out
because obstruction of justice in the
States requires a very specific
intention to do wrong and obstructed
investigation it's possible but I can't
answer that question based on what I
know but you you know you were in the
room the room where it happens when
Trump asked for personal loyalty and the
strong implication was linked to
dropping the investigation into my
clinic security adviser over the Russia
connection would that not sound to you
like a possible cause right that's why
my answer is it could be it's certainly
concerned me and the leaders of the FBI
a great deal but the ultimate question
depends upon facts that I'm sure that
special prosecutors work together that I
can't see what were the emails around it
what did the president say before and
after this those things that I don't
have access to would you like to see the
mother investigation conclude soon
because in many ways I mean you're a bit
on the prager as long as this goes on
you know that we wait and see how long
it comes out are you in the way have you
affected it I mean surely if you were
sitting in those shoes you would like
the investigation to be over soon sure
you you always do I remember over and
over again telling the Hillary Clinton
team that we need to do this quickly but
always well and if you have to choose
between them do it well so an absolute
revised lots of investigations you
always want to do it as soon as possible
but each case takes the time that it
takes to do it well so I don't know
whether Robert Muller is on the cusp of
finishing while I'm sitting here talking
to you or whether it will take months
more
and no one can tell because no one can
see what's going on inside his
investigation because it's a
professional investigation it is and it
hasn't leaked it's been a highly
professional investigation from that
point of view I mean there is another
optics problem which I'm sure was you're
probably unintended but with an awful
lot of people involved in it or have
been Democratic Party donors do you see
that that's an unfortunate perception
from the stance of those who may be
looking at it thinking you know did why
does my guy get a fair shot here yeah I
understand why partisans have seized on
that but I also understand why that the
director Muller is actually forbidden by
American law from asking people career
people inside the Department of Justice
about their political affiliation in
hiring them because we want people to be
able to have their own political views I
also know the culture of the Department
of Justice that the worst thing you can
do at the department justice is reflect
in your work of political bias which is
why the Inspector General's report
focused so much on the activity of FBI
people in that regard
so I get why partisans would seize on it
but it's it's highly misleading to use
that to try and attack the special
prosecutor he can't know that when he
hires people he hires them based on
their intelligence and their experience
not because there is inherently a
tendency for people there in that
organization to be more politically one
way than the other no and look a lot of
the prosecutors that he hired were the
best from New York and so you do the
math New York is a largely democratic
community and so the law of numbers
would tell you you maybe should divide
them for somewhere else well maybe but
he wants to hire the best he's not
considering politics and so some of the
very best minds in American law
enforcement especially on the
prosecution side are in the US Attorneys
offices in Manhattan and in Brooklyn so
if you want to hire the best athletes
you go where they're the strongest
especially because you don't care what
their politics are you need high
intelligence and high ability you've
watched how Trump responds to pressure
place up do you think he'll testify you
could even risk being subpoenaed I don't
know I would hope that he would
cooperate again he's the American
president and this is a lawful
appropriate investigation by the Justice
Department and I mean he once said to me
and I wrote this down in a memo right
afterwards that if one of his satellites
meaning someone around him had done
something wrong in connection with
Russia would be good to find out I hope
he still feels that way and would
cooperate given his role now I'm not his
personal lawyer so I can't advise him on
whether that stepping aside from the
role of president whether that would be
a smart move as a citizen I but I would
hope as an American president he would
cooperate and what's the best way to
cooperate just to go talk to the inquiry
or to set terms well you know anybody
speaking to a prosecutor wants to set
some kind of terms for how long it will
go on and that sort of thing but you had
to submit to an interview it would
strike me as a responsible thing to do
when you're the president of the United
States you hadn't been fired so publicly
from your job you'd be in charge of the
investigation after you wish you were in
mother's shoes huh
that's hard to say I wish I was still at
the FBI because of the people and their
mission and Bob Muller's got an
incredibly hard job to do and no matter
where he ends up he it's very similar to
where I was a year ago he will be
savagely attacked by at least one team
maybe but I've been attacked by both
teams maybe he'll anger both teams but
what's amazing about a person like Bob
Muller is he doesn't care and and so I
wish I was still involved in the mission
with the people of the FBI is the best
answer how does the FBI need to change
that in many ways everything about this
situation is suboptimal does it make you
think that there are things that the FBI
needs to do very differently or that
it's an institution that is right the
change I don't think that I think of
course there are things the FBI can do
better we were constantly finding ways
to improve every organization should
but it's it's at its core incredibly
healthy place and not politicized it's
being politically attacked but the
notion that it's politicized is just
nonsense and everybody who knows it
including some of the people who are
saying that know better so I don't see
there were important things I was trying
to change about the FBI but not its core
culture and commitment to the rule of
law that's rock-solid actually it should
be a consolation to the American people
that can't be screwed up even by a
president who constantly attacks it so
when Rudy Giuliani for instance says
that last week's Inspector General
report in your case it means that this
is a one reason where the Muller
investigation is so flawed and should be
called off what do you think said
Giuliani's motivation is he represents a
client and I don't I can't figure out
what his strategy is but he's obviously
trying to pursue some sort of strategy
by saying things like that
I don't doesn't make any sense to me
what are you saying but I I don't know
exactly why he's saying it other than to
say he's representing a client and so
he's saying things he thinks help the
client it is possible we use the word
collusion repeated about whether it's an
unpleasant word isn't it has very
unpleasant conse to do I think you
pointed out numerous times it isn't a
crime call collusion no I've never heard
of it before so does that mean that we
could actually be if this resonates an
American but hunting the snark you know
we could be looking for you unicorn a
unicorn is not but that doesn't really
exist that what we find is lots of
things that don't look too good about
the Trump administration's dealings with
Russia unwise perhaps foolish but in the
end no criminal that could happen but
that's not wouldn't be a product of
focus on collusion that I hate to get
all lawyer on you but collusion is just
not a term in American law what is being
investigated is conspiracy did anyone
knowing what the Russians were up to
assist them in their efforts or what we
call aiding and abetting did anyone
knowing what the Russians were doing
participate to help them and so that's a
sensible thing to look at you still
could end up in a place where you don't
find enough to conclude
is criminal wrongdoing and I suspect if
that's what the facts are that's what
his conclusion will be and is your
personal view that Russia had is
culpable of that kind of activity
towards the American democratic process
Oh overwhelmingly that that's not even a
serious question that the serious
question is were there any Americans who
with knowledge of what the Russians were
doing assisted it helped it participate
in it that's the question that the
special prosecutor has to focus on
I'm curious that you talk in the book
about your prosecution of many mafia
figures mobsters you've compared Trump
to a mafia boss and yet he does seem
like the Teflon man very little really
seems materially to alter his situation
as president you think he stains those
who come into contact with his
administration what would finally stain
Trump
well the rhythm of history of American
history tells us that eventually the
American people in their great mass will
tire of him and come to realize that he
threatens what is essentially America
which is our values and you're starting
to see a little of that with the
treatment of children at the border but
if history is a guide and I believe it
is the American people will tire of the
show and come to see that whatever trade
they convince themselves was worth it to
elect such a person it isn't in the long
run worth it to trade our values for the
rhetoric the promises of a particular
person like that you Ansem made some
people better if Trump doesn't get a
second term that if you're still having
to say that with the possibility of
two-term Trump presidency that prospects
hold for you what's possible and and
look it's the responsibility of the
American people I hope to be part of a
conversation to awaken the giant that is
the American people that are essentially
ethical good people and have them
realize that a threat to our values
transcends politics and that you can't
have a president who doesn't reflect
American values now maybe that won't
happen maybe the the fever won't break
until a second term but the lesson of
American
history as it inevitably breaks Joseph
McCarthy was the senator from Wisconsin
who dominated American politics from
1950 to 54 people in his party were
afraid to stand up to him to say he was
acting inappropriately and the fever
broken Joseph McCarthy was ruined and
then disgraced and left office and
that's the rhythm of America news feed
divas an interesting metaphor do you
think that Trump is a kind of illness in
the political system he's not he
reflects a pain in an illness that is a
regular feature of American life we make
great progress there's change and
turbulence and pain and then we suffer a
period of fever and then we recover and
we're stronger for it I know this sounds
like a strange thing but actually Donald
Trump in many ways unintentionally on
his part is actually helping America
because we're so caught fighting about
policy issues that we lose sight of many
times what unites us there's a
revisiting of people's view of George W
Bush and Barack Obama both of whom were
viciously attacked by partisan
opposition now people are stepping back
and saying wait a minute both of those
people were committed to American values
wow we need that in the Oval Office and
that's an obviously not Donald Trump's
intention but by example he's showing us
what we need and in an odd way that's
healthy for us you're getting now to
start in another phase of your career
just start teaching you'll get back to
college tell me a bit about that I'm
gonna teach in a public policy course at
the College of William and Mary
part-time in Washington part-time down
in there Virginia campus to about 30
students and I'm incredibly excited
about it we're gonna have my book as
part of the curriculum which I'm giving
to the students because I never like
those professors who made me buy their
book but we're also gonna read books
Hannah Aaron's book on the origins of
totalitarianism serious books Reinhold
Niebuhr to think and talk about
leadership what people are like and how
given our flaws as human beings leaders
should think and act and this generation
of students that you will be teaching
how do you think that they should act
should think should prepare themselves
to
active citizens and perhaps be more
effective given the events in in the
last few years in America than their
parents generation what do they need to
get right
first get enthusiasm right and they've
got it I mean the number of students who
wanted to be in this course is some
example of it but around the country I
see a hunger and young people my fear
was they would react to this ickiness in
American politics by pulling away
they're not there leaning forward so
that's the most important thing keep
that enthusiasm and learn to be a
quality thinker learn to understand
other people's perspectives to question
your own to make ethical leadership is
not about the decision you make it's
about the way you make a decision right
people aren't always gonna agree with
your decisions but did you think about
sources of authority about external
reference points did you have a quality
environment in which you made the
decision where men and women could speak
the truth to each other that's ethical
leadership and so to be an ethical
leader you have to become a quality
thinker expose yourself to other points
of view okay see that if somebody says
well that's fine that's the mark Ruby
the mic review is you used what we
clearly it was private conversations
private memos which I think you're still
being investigated because in the end
you decided that your take on ethics
mattered more than the sort of common or
garden respectful privacy in memos with
the White House now that I know that's
silly I mean you're not silly but I've
heard that that critique as a private
citizen I can speak about share and
write about conversations with the
president that aren't classified and
I've done that my book was reviewed all
of those conversations are in the book
reviewed by the FBI for classified
material there's none it's a long
tradition in American life people leave
office and write reflections on their
time in office that's actually I think
good for us so the notion that I was
doing something improper is frivolous
any reflections on the mood that you're
seeing here in Britain does it feel
interesting or puzzling to walk into
London in the middle of another week of
brexit storms well people in the UK are
interested in the kinds of issues and
values challenges that we're wrestling
with in the United States so there's an
engagement here that is palpable and the
weather's always good in London so I've
heard James give me thanks very much for
joining us thanks for having me